how's it going read names parapa it's
time for tomorrow oculus rift horror
that's what it's called splinter I think
no [ __ ]
it's called squish it's called linger
now I'm just confused it's all about
being professional let's get in this
[ __ ] whoa I can see my butt whoop is
amazing I always wanted to have my body
my foot I'm a woman does that mean I
can't see my test all right interact F
and G whoa all right I'm a cleaning lady
what's up what's up I'm I clean your
face well Walt has been here with this
dirty hey what are you doing what was
that am i walking it's Coney
hello sicko yeah close there you go it's
clean it's clean it's all clean
Jackie blue [ __ ] what's with all the
knocking what's doing how are you doing
that have a clean your way
I must spray tan your [ __ ] that's
more of a hey ho jab nada [ __ ] like
spike scare my tits off read the win you
don't even have Ted I don't even have
text this is a true nightmare after all
I thought I'd clean everything or what
is the point
this [ __ ] creaming what am i cleaning
anyway I hate my life these books here
before what are you doing stop
electricity doesn't even know how to
electrify my area okay
so far the game plays which are not what
you held back that your course might
pause my door I closed your head whoa
whoa I'm high
oh man look at them tattoos look at em
bazongas
[Music]
what says that you what is this thing
okay so wheels come on what do you want
from me
Oh [ __ ] do didn't like it that I cleanse
your spirit in the name of the holy
penis / spirit I cleanse you now look at
my tat tat - it doesn't work what the
[ __ ] scheme so unrealistic
seriously I'm here to clean and you're
making a maze now I'm pissed
it has to be holy water and that's like
ectoplasm and [ __ ] like that I know
because I what what the hell is hot what
the [ __ ] what's that it threw himself at
me I don't know whatever oh oh oh I
never said the b-word hi hi I never said
the b-word I was gonna say what about
that beautiful woman that's what I was
got you you didn't know what did you
know you can't take words in my mouth
I'm not offending anyone we're all
friends okay we all friends right hello
hello anyone here it's gonna pee on that
thing I'm just in it innocent little
cleaning lady what do you want from me
ah who you think you are you can't touch
my titties what
all my tips are still there don't worry
okay good there has to be more blue blue
goo well there is that you cooking son
of a [ __ ] okay no it's not your tits
are on the floor mines are way better
you can never had my Tatas you will
never have my Joss that's not what's
today close to done oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is crazy
that [ __ ] is crazy well I'm sure as
hell ain't never becoming a cleaning
lady I don't care how it's sexy my
assets she was enjoying linger you're
like if you did
cuz this guy conver it today
[Music]
out of here I don't wanna face quest
today
I'm so happy oh but I said I'll do it